we go it's from the Southern Festival of
Books in Nashville Tennessee and is just
under an hour you probably know Tony
Horwitz my name is athelia pained you
probably know that Tony Horwitz you
probably know him as the author of the
bestselling novels Confederates in the
Attic Baghdad without a map and one for
the road
educated at Brown University and
Columbia's Graduate School of Journalism
he is also a Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist who has worked as a foreign
correspondent for The Wall Street
Journal and as a staff writer for The
New Yorker his wife Geraldine Brooks is
also a featured author at this festival
in blue latitudes boldly going where
Captain Cook has gone before our speaker
along with his good mate Roger who is
not here today
I don't think follows in the wake of the
enigmatic Captain James Cook the 18th
century explorer who sailed over a
hundred and fifty thousand miles from
the Arctic to the Antarctic from Tahiti
to Bora Bora to New Zealand Siberia
Alaska Hawaii and many places in between
no less an adventurer himself in my book
Tony Horwitz began his own journey with
a harrowing seven-day voyage aboard a
replica of cook ship the Endeavour Blue
latitudes has been hailed by critics as
and I quote alternately hilarious
poignant and insightful a rollicking
read that is also a sneaky work of
scholarship please join me in welcoming
Tony Horwitz
thanks for that and thanks for coming
today I was last year I think four years
ago talking about Confederates in the
Attic and I'm delighted that the
Southern Festival of Books has expanded
its definition of the south to include
the deep deep south of Australia and New
Zealand and Antarctica so I could come
here again Confederates in the Attic was
largely about how we remember the past
and at times miss remember it Blue
latitudes is turning out to be the same
the first review of my book rendered the
subtitle is boldly going where Captain
Hook has gone before I know my
six-year-old son was disappointed that
this isn't really what the book is about
and I'm sorry I won't be talking about a
Captain Hook today or Captain Kidd who's
another one it causes some confusion I
did want to say a few words about
Captain Kirk of the Starship Enterprise
because that is what the subtitle refers
to and I do think it's relevant to cook
story first of all if there any Star
Trek fans out there the show was
completely lifted from history Captain
James Kirk Captain James Cook Kirk's
Starship Enterprise cook ship endeavour
Kirk boldly going where no man has gone
before
cook riding the same exact words almost
in his own log but I didn't mean this
just as a flip pop-culture reference I
do think as we today try and grasp the
immensity of what Cook did over 200
years ago both geographically and
psychologically it helps to keep in mind
the image of shooting into space and
beaming down to planets rather as
Captain Kirk did with his crew in Star
Trek when cook first set off for the
Pacific in 1768 on the first of his
three epic voyages of discovery
theorists of the day thought that a vast
southern continent encircled the bottom
of the globe and that was filled with
gold and spice and 50 million people
they thought that open ocean didn't
freeze and that
for it was possible to sail from the
Atlantic to the Pacific over the North
Pole
they thought that Patagonian is in South
America were 10 feet tall in other words
they didn't have a clue what was out
there and cook sailed into this void in
a small wooden ship with only 94 men and
came back three years later with about
40 of those men dead with reports of
lands and plants and animals so strange
that Europeans didn't even know what to
do with them one of the things the
endeavor brought home was a the first
specimen in Europe of a kangaroo
Europeans just didn't have any any
analogy to describe this creature and
the botanist on board cook ship called
it an 80-pound mouse but to me the most
compelling part of cook's discovery is
the first contact between European and
Pacific peoples across the great ocean
at land after land cook beams down in
this case you know rowing his jolly boat
ashore with no idea of who he's going to
encounter how they're going to
communicate and how they're going to get
along and whether he'll be greeted with
spears or embraces this is an experience
we we simply can't have today cook sort
of ruined it for us yet he had it dozens
of times and what's also remarkable as
he left us a very vivid record of what
it's like what really drew me in to cook
story was a chance encounter with Cook's
journals of discovery I fell in love
with an Australian almost twenty years
ago and got dragged off to Sydney and
just came upon these journals and was
immediately drawn in first of all by the
adventure story that's that's in there
this isn't the rather dry story that we
learned about in fifth grade geography
class it's filled with cannibals and
human sacrifice and orgies and icebergs
it's really a thrilling tale but also
cook and his men were were the first
scientific explorers his ships were
filled with trained observers botanists
are
as astronomers even poets on his last
voyage so that they leave us a very
vivid record that's accessible to us
today they thought of themselves as men
of the Enlightenment they write in this
very empirical fashion even about the
most exotic scenes it's a lot like
reading of Lewis and Clark's journals of
discovery it's at once wonderfully
exotic and also strikingly modern but
the deeper I got into this the more I
became entranced by Cooke the man I
think I was initially drawn more to his
voyages but he's his story almost defies
belief this man who explored more of the
Earth's surface than anyone in history
came from the most provincial pinched
background imaginable he was born in a
mud and thatch hovel in rural Yorkshire
the son of an illiterate day laborer
really the very bottom of British
society in the 18th century he had
almost no formal education he left
school to work on the farm with his
father and then to become a shop
assistant yet he did something
remarkable he ran away to see as a
teenager and taught himself astronomy
and navigation and became so skilled at
this that the maps he later made of the
Pacific were still in use until the
1990s and he made these maps with none
of the tools we have today from a ship
at sea lands that were entirely unknown
and to me it's obvious Cook was a
prodigy he was a once-in-a-generation
figure entirely self educated and self
created who just sort of bursts out of
nowhere to transform his world in ours
what's also very striking about Cook's
story though is that the voyages for
which he's most famous to the Pacific
occurred in his 40s we think about his
mid life today I certainly hope it is
but in his day it was a lot closer to
the grave after his first voyage to the
Pacific he was already a famous man
after his second voyage he was offered a
very cushy retirement in London he had a
wife
and family there yet he chose in his
late 40s to set off yet again on another
reckless voyage of discovery one that
ultimately cost him his life and much of
my book is an attempt to understand what
what drove this man to make these
voyages off the known map over and over
again he was obviously a very daring and
insatiably curious figure as great as as
cooks story is I didn't want to tell it
simply as traditional history or
biography one reason is that it's
impossible to read Cook's journals
without becoming Restless yourself
you're sitting there in the archives and
you're thinking you know it's a little
again like reading Lewis and Clark where
you want to climb out you know and climb
over the back fence and just sort of
head west with cook you have to go a
little further than that but you want to
see the places he did and experience
some of that thrill of discovery
I'm also as I did in Confederates in the
Attic I wanted to write not just about
the past but about how we understand and
feel history today and I began my voyage
in in cooks wake is Ophelia mentioned by
signing on as a working crewman on a
replica of cook's first ship the
endeavor i wanted to experience
firsthand what it was like to be an 18th
century seaman it sucks the the endeavor
was a converted coal ship it was
basically a wobbly wooden tub with no
concession to comfort or aesthetics the
sailors slept in hammocks that were
really no more than straight jackets
with just 14 inches between them that
was the the amount of space allotted by
the British Admiralty in the 18th
century the notion of personal space
that we have today simply didn't exist
but you really don't sleep at all
because you're constantly being called
on deck to pull ropes and shove the
capstan and shift sails or to do the job
that I dreaded most which was going
aloft I was assigned to main mast which
is 127 feet tall
hi radically amplifies the motion of a
ship and because the Endeavour has a
very shallow keel it's it's a very
wobbly ship to begin with and in heavy
seas if the deck is moving like this if
you're up on the top of the the main
mast it's going like this and also like
this because you're pitching into waves
it's a bit like being on a roller
coaster except that you also have to
work you're up there on this standing on
this drooping foot line and clinging to
the spar was sort of like a drunken
pencil it's going like this and reaching
over to Ferol and unfurl heavy sails or
tie and untie knots upside down while
try not to look down at the sea you know
over a hundred feet below I thought that
civil war be enacting was the worst
thing I'd ever do for the sake of a good
story but I'd much rather a spoon with
smelly Confederates again and eat hard
tack then go up the mast of the endeavor
one more time it's it's that horrible
but I don't want to suggest that this is
in any way comparable to what Cook and
his men did but it gave me some insight
into that they set off for three years
at a time with no contact with home
without so much as a life raft I spoke
earlier about shooting into space well
astronauts today have a contact with
Mission Control they have a
reconnaissance scheduled they have
high-tech gear a cook sailed off without
even a decent chart and the men while we
usually associate cook with Hawaii and
Tahiti in the South Pacific in fact his
last two voyages were to the Antarctic
and Arctic Cook was the first to pierce
the Antarctic Circle and he later sailed
just as far north into the Arctic so his
men were up on this mast battling
frostbite and scurvy and what they
called nostalgia which was intense
homesickness one of those sailors wrote
off Antarctica being driven mad by the
melancholy croaking of innumerable
penguins 40% of kooks men died on his
first voyage which I think gives you a
little indication of how hazardous
this was they were also of course lashed
at sea when they got out of line and
they were fed really filthy rations
mostly salt pork and salt beef and bread
so foul that the ship's naturalist
described shaking thousands of vermin
from a single ship's biscuit before
eating it he also described the taste of
each of these insects the Cook on the
Endeavour had only one hand which i
think is sort of a fair indicator of how
much emphasis the British Navy put on
the quality of food and when those
rations ran out the sailors foraged for
whatever they could find in the Arctic
Cooke had them hunting for walrus which
Cook was a very stoic eater and he
called it marine beef but his men found
it so disgusting that they almost mutiny
until he restored their their salt
rations in my own travels and Cook's
wake I I met a man in the Bering Sea who
had eaten walrus and asked him what it
tasted like and he described it as
Crisco with mass so yummy anyway after
this rather daunting sale on the replica
endeavour I set off in cooks wake island
hopping in the order that he did
beginning at Tahiti which was his first
landfall in the Pacific in 1769 of
course Tahiti carries with it this
tremendous romance of of primal image
innocence and and libertine society and
much of this really comes from cook and
his men they had just sailed eight
months in these horrible conditions the
only females on board were the milk goat
and one of the botanist dogs they
arrived in Tahiti which is this
beautiful island where a naked women are
beckoning them from the beach and
exchanging their favors for a single
ship snail
there was no metal in Polynesia and
Islanders quickly recognized the value
of these nails which could be turned
into fish hooks
as a result English ships visiting
Tahiti had a tremendous problem because
the sailors pried so many nails from the
ships that they almost fell apart
and the men we're all sleeping on the
deck because they pulled out the nails
holding up their hammocks I'm sorry to
say Tahiti isn't quite as a welcoming
and as inexpensive today in fact its
ruinously expensive now it's a long way
from anywhere and sadly much of the
culture that cooks all is now gone and
one reason for that is along with nails
cooks man and later visitors brought
disease and as a result many of these
societies we're almost wiped out
following the first European contact
cook estimated the population of Tahiti
at over 200,000 when they did the first
French census - two generations later
- only 7,000 Islanders remaining and I
think that gives you some sense of the
fatal impact of European arrival I went
to many other islands where the impact
of Cook's voyages wasn't always so
severe the Royal Kingdom of Tonga is one
of the more bizarre places I visited the
Tongans so admired cooking his men and
the English who came later that they
refashion their society in the image of
Britain they created an absolute
monarchy with a king named George
they created a titled nobility with
coats of arms but what's interesting is
that while Britain has obviously changed
a lot since the 18th century Tonga has
not it's still basically a feudal
society I had an audience with the
current king who lives in a palace by
the sea and learned that he's quite an
eccentric fellow he's been in the
Guinness Book of World Records as the
world's weightiest monarch at 444 pounds
yet he also holds the pole vault record
in Tonga uh-huh a record I'd add that I
don't think any of his subjects are
rushing to break he also told me about
riding around the palace grounds since
the child on the back of a tortoise that
Captain Cook left with his
great-great-great grandfather and
miraculously the tortoise survived this
large child and its remains were in a
Tong and Museum it lived until the 1960s
the
also has a court jester who rather
bizarrely he entrusted with investing
the Tongan Treasury which is now gone I
also went to the Great Barrier Reef off
Australia where Cooke almost sank the
endeavor when he ran into the coral he
had no way of knowing that there was
this 2,000 mile reef along the coast of
Australia and he limped ashore in Far
North Queensland at a remote outback
place that's now known as Cooke town I
went there for an annual celebration
they have each year to honor cooks
arrival and rather typically a reverent
Australian fashion this is basically an
excuse for drinking vast amounts of beer
I saw a person there with the t-shirt
bearing the unofficial motto of Cooktown
which is the liver is evil and must be
punished for old times sake I
participated in the reenactment there of
cooks Landing and it wasn't quite as
sober as my reenactments and
Confederates in the attic but
interesting nonetheless but I don't want
to suggest that my travels in cooks wake
we're all beer drinking and antics
although there was plenty of that
everywhere I went I wanted to try and
understand what that experience of first
contact had been like for both the
discovered and the discoverers and and
what it means today what the legacy of
it is it's obviously very hard to get
inside the heads of Islanders at the
time of cook's arrival they didn't have
a written language yet remarkably some
very interesting oral accounts do
survive you know if you think about it
for a minute while cooking his men at
least expected to encounter foreign
cultures for those they met they had no
basis for even imagining a white man in
tall ships suddenly appearing over the
horizon the only thing that might be
analogous today would be if a spaceship
landed in our backyard and green men
stepped out to greet us
except that of course Hollywood has
prepared us even for that
curiously some of those who first met
cook called the moon men they did think
they were from another planet the
Hawaiians saw there saw these strange
people for the first time and thought
they had loose wrinkled skin which was
of course clothing and treasure holes
and their sides which were pockets and
burning volcanoes in their mouths which
were pipes of tobacco the Maori in New
Zealand saw this strange ship coming
ashore and thought it was a floating
island the mass being trees and then
they saw these pale men or pale
creatures they didn't know what they
were climbing into small boats and
rowing ashore with their backs to their
land to the land and they thought they
were goblins with eyes in the backs of
their heads in my own travels I found
rather sadly that many Maori and others
in the Pacific still see Cooke as a
goblin the reason is that while he was
in my view a humane explorer who tried
to avoid violence and the spread of
disease he didn't always succeed but but
he tried many of those who came in his
wake were not so sensitive and they
brought with them not only disease but
rum guns other ills that either largely
wiped out the population or transformed
it missionaries were often well-meaning
rooted out native belief and customs so
that really these societies to a large
degree where were transformed within a
generation or two of kooks visit and
this was really the central
contradiction of his voyages he was sent
off to explore and describe not to
conquer and convert but he was also told
to claim lands for Britain and to treat
the natives with respect the problem is
that his very arrival initiated a
process that changed these societies
inexorably and he himself began to sense
this by his third voyage he has some
rather despairing passages
in which he wonders whether it would
have been better off if he had never met
these people before at least that they
would have been better off if they had
never encountered his ships and as a
result he's not seen in a very kindly
way and much of the Pacific today for
instance when I went to Hawaii to his
death sighted Kealakekua Bay the
monument to Cook has been defaced and
the words captain crook and why do you
go home written on it on the other hand
in Hawaii and almost everywhere else I
went I found an interesting twist which
is that there's a tremendous revival of
indigenous arts and culture underway and
the Pacific really as there is across
the world and as part of this cook is
being rediscovered in a more positive
light the reason is that the art and
writing of his men and the artifacts
they collected which they called
artificial curiosities give us the best
really the only snapshot we have of what
life was like in the Pacific at the
moment of European contact if it had
been whaling ships that had arrived
first we simply wouldn't have these
records but what we have are these
wonderfully detailed journals paintings
and other things that allow us a window
really into the Pacific in the 1770s and
native people are now using these
records to reclaim what was lost for
instance I sailed into the island of
Bora Bora at night and found women in a
clearing in the woods doing a
traditional dance and the man who was
judging the this performance explained
to me that when these dances were
revived in recent decades after a
hundred and fifty years of missionaries
suppression that the art and writing of
cook and his men were invaluable to
understanding what these dances had been
like in the same way in New Zealand the
Maori are now studying cook's artwork
and journals to understand facial
tattooing which is being revived in in
in New Zealand and had been outlawed
over a hundred years ago and they're
also learning about the construction of
their canoes and they're even using
Cook's journals as evidence in their
and claims against the government as our
Aborigines in Australia for instance in
New Zealand Maori are turning to a line
and cook's journals where he sees
fishing canoes 12 miles offshore and
they're saying that's the extent of our
traditional fishing ground and we'd like
it back to me this is a an encouraging
twist to the story and also one that's
truer to cook the man I think it's easy
to dismiss these early explorers as
conquistadors and killers cook really
wasn't like that and while I think we
obviously need to recognize the damage
done in his wake and do what we can to
repair it we shouldn't at the same time
dismiss his humanity and it recognized
perhaps even what we can learn from it
today I wrote this book against the
backdrop of September 11th and while I
don't refer to it in my book I couldn't
help becoming aware as I was writing my
book that while we are busy barricading
ourselves against the rest of the world
and looking looking at the rest of the
world with a fear and suspicion cook
story is about the opposite it's about
being open and curious and and setting
forth to to meet other people and and
wherever possible to treat them with
respect and I thought I'd end by just
reading a short passage from my book and
then I'll open it up for questions and
comments and abuse I my last stop is
Hawaii because that was after all Cook's
last stop he was actually cooked there
we won't go into that now but I met a
very interesting Hawaiian artist named
herb kawainui Khanna who posed an
interesting a thought which is that
contrary to what we might think today
that the English and the Polynesians may
have actually gotten along quite well
and even had more in common with each
other than they have with other
Europeans or Polynesians today and I'll
just read a bit about sort of being back
at my hotel and waking up in the middle
of the night and reflecting on this
I've been traveling the Pacific for 18
months during which I've been tethered
to home by telephone email and hotel TV
I couldn't even begin to grasp what it
had been like to stay continuously at
sea for twice that long and in cook's
case to make such a voyage three times
completely cut off from familiar
surrounds with the strong possibility
that you'd never return home there were
no women on board no old people no
children for cooking his men the life
they'd known in England must have come
to seem very unreal I tried to imagine
then how the men felt each time they
came ashore in Hawaii or Tonga or Tahiti
fresh food terra firma and female flesh
were no doubt the main attractions of
land but there must have been something
else a desperate need to connect for
lack of a better word the sailors
tattoos their fascination with native
customs and rituals all this spoke to a
desire to feel at home and fit in
Islanders for the most part warm and
hospitable and curious reciprocated as
herb said the two peoples may have felt
a kinship or forged one in a way that
was hard to appreciate now influenced as
we are by the horrors that resulted from
first contact and by the prevailing
notion that all viewpoints are quote
culturally determined creating an almost
Umbridge well divide between Western and
non-western societies for all the
violence and exploitation that occurred
during Cook's voyages what struck me in
the end was that the English and those
they encountered had managed to
communicate and in most cases to get
along the two groups came from opposite
ends of the globe usually knew nothing
of each other and often had not so much
as a single word in common yet they
almost always made themselves understood
with a smile and embrace her nose press
the presentation of a plant is a sign of
peace the offer of a gift cook
understood this Esperanto better than
any man on board his ship if there was
an overriding message in his journals it
was the people the world over were alike
in their essential nature even if they
ate their enemies made love in public
worshipped idols or like Aborigines
cared not at all
Tyrael goods no matter how strange
another society might at first appear
there were almost always grounds for
mutual understanding and respect this
was a radical notion in 18th century
Europe and it seemed relevant to me more
than 200 years later at a time when so
much of the world appeared dangerously
divided along ethnic religious and
ideological lines thanks very much
we're we're glad you hear and I love the
book would you expound a little bit on
Joseph Banks his entourage and his
relationship with Cooke I didn't mention
my talk but the other main historical
player in this story is Joseph Banks
who's wonderful because he's the
complete opposite of cook while cook
comes from the bottom of British society
Joseph Banks comes from the very top at
the age of 25 he's already one of the
wealthiest men of his day a landed
gentleman educated at Eton and Oxford
and he pays the equivalent of about a
million dollars to a company cook on his
first voyage as a botanist and he brings
along with him two assistants two
artists two servants two footmen and two
dogs
his Greyhound and spaniel this was a man
who liked to travel in style on cook
second voyage he tried to sneak aboard a
mistress disguised as a man but what's
remarkable is that this Odd Couple this
landed gentleman and this poor boy from
Yorkshire who are 15 years apart in age
become friends in the course of the
voyage and forged one of the great
partnerships in the history of
exploration while Cooke is sort of very
much the the unflappable commander
navigating through reefs and storms and
everything else Banks is the passionate
young romantic who's hurling himself
into the experience of Island culture
he's participating in Island rituals he
tells us about his love affairs with
Island women about his terror it see and
he also becomes really one of the
world's first anthropologists he
collects native languages he he leaves
us a very vivid record that's a
complimentary view to cooks it's a lot
like Lewis and Clark again we see the
same voyage through very different eyes
so it's really a
wonderful and unlikely story and also
banks goes on to sort of become the
executor of kooks legacy after cook dies
he he sees to it that cooks
accomplishments are remembered and
followed up on don't be shy here come on
fire away I see someone here you know
yeah yes I haven't had a chance to read
the book yet but did he have trouble
maintaining his cruise once I got to the
island that they don't want to get back
on and keep going with him and then
we're natives curious and got on with
them and took off as well it's a very
good question about the temptations on
these islands and how he controlled his
crew this certainly was a problem he got
to Tahiti and several of his men
deserted and took island wives
understandably this looked like a pretty
appealing life compared to either going
back to sea or returning to England they
were retrieved and brought back on board
Cooke didn't spare the lash he was a
disciplinarian and one thing that's
interesting is that one of the men on
his last voyage was William Bligh who
went on of course to return to he D in
the bounty and we all know about his
problems what's interesting is in the in
the kind of endless archival research I
did for this book you stumble on some
strange things and one it was a study of
how many lashes each English captain
gave to their crew in the 18th century I
someone went through and added them all
up the English of course were great
record keepers so we can reconstruct you
know exactly each flogging and it turns
out that Bligh was the gentlest
English commander in the Pacific in the
18th century Cooke was kind of
middle-of-the-road he lashed about a
quarter of his men on the first voyage
so in fact belies problems possibly we
think of him as this sort of tyrant in
fact he may not have exercised enough
discipline as horrible as it is to think
as to Islanders themselves coming along
again there's a wonderful parallel to
Lewis and Clark they get to Tahiti on
the first voyage and a Tahitian priest
named to
I asked to come along on their onward
voyage he's essentially a Polynesian
Sacagawea he serves as an interpreter
and go-between at the other islands they
go to and as many of you may know
Polynesia is a fantastic Society and
that they themselves had explored and
spread all across the Pacific so that
when the endeavor gets to New Zealand
thousands of miles away to paya is able
to communicate with the Maori of New
Zealand because they had migrated from
that area 600 years or so before so he's
a crucial player in this story sadly he
dies on the voyage home so that we don't
we don't get his personal story which
would be wonderful to have
I'm interested in some of the mechanics
of how some of these things were
possible three things especially did you
ever get a better ship so that well you
know that it actually sailed secondly
how did he keep his people alive how did
Drake how did Magellan any of these
people keep people alive without any
vitamins or you know I just you know
diet wise and thirdly how did they find
how it was he just lucky to find all the
major islands in this middle of nowhere
out there how did he how did they
navigate you know to get to these places
three very good questions first about
the ship as kind of unwieldy a ship as
the endeavor was it was actually well
suited to the task first of all because
it was basically a cargo ship designed
to carry call and they had to carry a
lot of I should have mentioned they
carried not only the man and and all
their stores they also carried there
their livestock they had cattle and
sheep and goats and chickens I mean the
quarterdeck was kind of a barnyard as
unbelievable to think of you know
ninety-four men and all these animals
crammed into a ship only a hundred feet
long but it was also a very tough ship
it survived this encounter with the with
the reef so he did have a different ship
on the second and third voyage called
the resolution and he also had
companionships it was basically just a
bigger version of the endeavor it was
also a coal ship but but larger but not
not that much sturdier incredibly cooked
sail to the Arctic and the Antarctic
without any sheathing on his ship you
know he was sailing between icebergs it
really is remarkable as to how you know
they kept men alive I mean it's another
remarkable story Cook was one of the
first to not lose any men to scurvy it
wasn't quite for the reasons they
thought as sort of like spaceships today
the endeavor was loaded with all these
experimental food items they had a lot
of sauerkraut which they thought would
work something dreadful called a
portable soup which was kind of liver
and kidneys and other things boiled into
slabs and then dissolved various other
things marmalade on his second voyage
what really seems to have protected his
man is that cook was fanatical about
collecting fresh greens and vegetables
at every place he landed so while they
got symptoms of scurvy none of them
seemed to it appears that none of them
died from it that being said he did lose
40% of his men on his first voyage
mostly to dysentery
when they reached Indonesia on the
return trip they also you know they lost
some to drink the ones would have Salva
being a sailor in the 18th century is
you got a ration of about a gallon of
beer a day many of these men were more
or less drunk every day some of them
fell from the rigging one even fell from
the what they called the seats of ease
which were their lovely toilets which
were planks extending from the bow so
alcohol took its toll as well now remind
me your last question okay how he found
his way again when he set off they were
using much the tools they had for
centuries
Sexton Almanac a certain amount of dead
reckoning on his second voyage he
carried any of you who have read Dava
Sobel wonderful book longitude he
carried copies of Harrison's chronometer
x' and he was really the first to give
them the the real stamp of approval so
he was also crucial to that step forward
in the effort to to understand longitude
but on his first voyage he really was to
a great degree sailing blind and doing
what they called running surveys from
the deck of his ship and bobbing seas
again it's it's astounding when you
think about it to make maps that were so
accurate you know with observations of
the Stars and the land and all the
mathematics involved
can you talk about the the ship's logs a
little bit in the documents that you
looked at was it only cook that did them
did other people do them are there
drawings what do they physically look
like question is about this sort of
primary material available the logs and
artwork and again as I mentioned briefly
when I was talking this is what really
drew me into cook you have this
wonderful record when you when you kind
of look at the voyages of Magellan for
instance I mean that's a great story too
but what was left isn't terribly
credible you have people writing about
sea monsters and it was a different era
they wrote differently with cooks again
you have this you know what seems they
were trying to be reliable they weren't
always but also this an unbelievable
volume of material cooks a journal
stretched to four volumes thousands of
pages Joseph Banks left a very long
journal as well and by his last voyage
the sailors themselves are conscious
that they're making history and also
that perhaps they can make money when
they get home by selling their stories
so they're keeping journals as well and
you have American sailors and Germans
you have this wonderful kind of Upstairs
Downstairs effect where you have the
officers keeping their journals and the
common sailors who cook called the
people keeping theirs so it gives this
wonderful sort of stereoscopic effect
you can take their visit to any given
place and and read five or six different
versions and kind of it helps you first
of all establish what happened but it
gives you some sense of the
relationships onboard it's quite
wonderful the artwork is equally
fantastic he had a trained artist on all
his voyages as he did a few drawings
himself the sailors did some drawings at
upaya the Polynesian priest learned to
paint he left us some wonderfully sort
of naive almost folk artists
representations of the voyage and and
it's just it's it's riveting you get a
real image of what these native people
look like we have the very first images
of what a Maori in New Zealand look like
with facial tattoos or a dance than
Tahiti so there's almost too much
material
real challenge for me and writing this
book was you know taking this acres of
material and sort of trying to boil it
down to the very best stuff so that it
wasn't you know this book wasn't 900
pages long and as it was I had to throw
a lot away but that was one of the real
pleasures really is the the wealth of
material there it's about how if 40% of
his men died you know how did they
essentially even man the ship and it
really was a crisis cook writes about
because not only did you have all these
men dying but most of the survivors were
sick themselves we don't know exactly
what they contracted in present-day
Jakarta was then called Batavia was a
Dutch port in Indonesia and cook had to
stop there to repair his ship and while
he was there almost everybody on board
the ship got sick and many of them died
so he writes about not you know barely
having enough healthy men to sail the
ship it's it's it's really frightening
others are caring for the sick or
desperately ill themselves you know and
and there's a kind of Anarchy that takes
hold - because they don't really know I
mean the understanding of medicine in
those days was you know very primitive
they didn't even know what they had it
might have been malaria typhoid fever we
don't really know for sure today so we
don't know if they're all gonna die and
some of them you know become you know
sort of a little bit sick and start
screaming I'm dying I'm dying one man
starts beating the sick just goes
berserk so it's a it's one of the darker
periods from Cook's voyages
luckily they then reach Cape Town and
for whatever reason it's a healthier
place and they start to recover so he
has enough man he also takes on more men
Capetown you know has enough men to sell
home but it is a it is a close call yeah
I don't I don't want to ruin any
surprises but I wondered if you would
give us an update on um
controversy about DNA in the in the aro
question is about a sort of strange
story I stumble on at the the end of my
book I begin and end my book with with
cooks very dramatic death and in Hawaii
and without giving away too much he's
he's cooked he's cut up and cooked and
his parts are you know partly buried at
sea and partly they just disappeared the
Hawaiians seem to regard them as sacred
relics and I made a rather bizarre
discovery part of the fun of trying to
fill in the blanks around cooks story is
there are still things to find out and
one that I found out was that there's
this arrow in the basement of a sydney
museum that's allegedly made from Cook's
shin bone and it comes with a whole
provenance letters from the 19th century
explaining how this ended up in the
museum of course we don't know for sure
if it's if it's real there are millions
of dubious relics around the world for
instance you can go to something like
six museums and find the dagger with
which Cook was killed so there's an
understandable skepticism on the part of
museum officials and they're now trying
to see if they can test it and determine
first of all if it's human it may be
marine mammal and secondly if it is
human if it is cooks and there's certain
the tests they've done so far indicate
it may well be human and would have come
from a sort of robust man of about the
age of fifty which obviously suits cook
the DNA is a little tricky because cooks
family history is quite tragic he had
six children all of whom died young
before they had children of their own
but his sister one of his sisters
survived
and her descendants actually are in
Australia and as some of you may know I
don't completely understand this but if
you get the mitochondria from the female
side you can in fact DNA test so the
story is not finished that's all I can
tell you there's it's it's in progress
so that's all I can say perhaps one more
question is yeah if there's or someone
who hasn't asked one yeah and who they
were and what part of society they came
from they were the common sailors the
people were pretty rough lot they came
from all over East London all parts of
Britain Ireland Scotland
some of them Venice you know really from
all over
they were mostly young men in their
teens and 20s by and large you know
working-class fellows we don't know a
huge amount about them because they
don't really appear in the ship's logs
unless they've died deserted or been
flogged on the later voyages yeah a few
of them keep journals we do have several
Americans aboard who one of kooks
higher-ups is a man named John Gore who
may or may not be related to the
Tennessee Gore's he's peers to be from
Virginia who's a great marksman and and
outlives Cooke and ends up sailing his
ship home you have Germans it's it's a
very cosmopolitan crew I find it most
interesting on the third voyage because
by then cook's a famous man and he he's
attracting poets thinkers others who are
recognizing this is this is something
you know to go to the other end of the
world and see all these strange things
and they even keep a newspaper on board
there's so many writers on board so you
know you have a really a fascinating mix
and to me that's part of the charm of
the story and many of them go on to do
great things I mean Cook was a great
educator as well so for instance
Vancouver
who sailed with him on the last voyage
goes on to explore much of the northwest
coast of America and Canada several of
them fight in the Napoleonic Wars others
come to Bad ends like Bligh
or die in duels and you know it's quite
a quite a colorful cast of characters
about the selection of the crew he
didn't have complete control for
instance they assigned him this cook
with one hand and he said you know I'd
really like someone who's not infirm and
they said sorry you know so he had some
but not complete control and there were
also repeats a number of the men you
know returned to sail a second and a
third time question is about the replica
of the endeavor that I wrote on it was
built by an Australian foundation it's a
non-profit exercise and it sails around
the globe in cooks wake it's been doing
this for a number of years now and at
each port it stops at it becomes a sort
of floating museum it'll stay there for
a few days then people can come aboard
and visit the ship unfortunately here in
Nashville it's not gonna make it here
but it's been up and down the the east
and west coasts of America and then they
take on volunteers like myself to sail
the next leg it's mostly sort of
demented people who have read too many
Patrick O'Brien novels and are infected
with the romance of tall ships and this
voyage tends to cure them very quickly
my own voyage you just apply and they
just sort of assign you to the next
available voyage my own was off the
Pacific Northwest from the state of
Washington up to British Columbia
yes it's in England with the question is
about my traveling companion Roger
Williamson I didn't really plan to take
on crew when I started this book Roger
is an old mate of mine from Australia
and I used Sydney as my base for
researching this book and he sort of
barged into my story a little bit the
way Joseph Banks barged into James
Cook's he's a curious mix of Banks and
cook like cook he's a very tall
broad-shouldered man who's from
originally from Yorkshire as cook is and
migrated to Australia he's also a great
sailor yet he's a little more like banks
and that he he kind of likes wine women
and song so he's kind of the foil I'm
kind of the straight guy in this book
Rob Roger is a sort of a Falstaff
looking for a good time wherever we go
but he also he brings some light relief
to the book I hope but also an
understanding of nautical matters and
also of class society and Britain in a
way that perhaps I could enhance oh I
enjoyed his company I hope I hope
readers do to anyone else yeah I'm sorry
for the future are you researching if
you can
or what kinds of things don't know
usually you have a long period between
finishing a book and when it's published
this one I only really finished the
final revisions in July so I haven't had
time to think about it I'd like to find
another Explorer I'm intrigued by these
characters but perhaps someone a little
closer to home this time this was a
great trip but I had to cover an awful
lot of ground it took me three years
perhaps something a little tad less
ambitious yeah yeah I wish I had Joseph
Banks along too
no I'm I'm lucky enough this is my
fourth book and I was lucky enough to
get an advance that was comfortable
enough for me to to take this trip and
also to bring along Roger who was
whatever the barbel alone was
considerable so you know if that's and
it is an issue in the Pacific it's it's
very expensive out there particularly in
Polynesia which is sort of a dumping
ground for the French for all the
products that have failed in Europe and
they shipped them over to the poor
colonists and in Tahiti and sell them at
these inflated prices so you do you if
any of you are headed over there on
vacation you do have to watch your
wallet
I'm sorry here that Steven Ambrose died
today yeah in a sense undaunted courage
was one of the inspirations for this
book you know to me under a Lewis and
Clark you know it's the great adventure
story in American history and in a real
sense they did on land what Cooke did it
see this this voyage of essentially
scientific discovery that led to
repeated encounters with natives who had
had little or no contact with Europeans
and in fact Cook's voyages led almost
directly to Lewis and Clark Jefferson
was a great admirer as was Franklin
Jefferson originally wanted to dispatch
a man named John Ledyard an American on
on cook's last voyage to do what Lewis
and Clark did he died and ended up
sending Lewis and Clark instead they
modeled their journals very consciously
on cook's so there are some very close
connections and also in what I mentioned
in my talk about the contradiction and
what they were doing again I think Lewis
and Clark were largely well-meaning
explorers yet by just by going there
they brought about the ruin of this you
know of both the environment and the
people that they went out there to to
find out about so I in many ways a very
very similar story
question is whether I was separated from
my family the whole time not as much as
cook cook was married for 17 years and
spent about two and a half of that with
his wife he was at sea almost all the
time
no I again set up base in Sydney which
is where my wife is from so she was
delighted to sort of be there doing her
own work and and with my son while I was
sailing around but I also did almost all
my primary research in Sydney which has
the world's best archives of cook
related material so yeah I did have long
periods where I was away but it wasn't I
wasn't away for three years now I was
coming back intermittently wasn't that
bad
Tony Hoare it's his book blue latitudes
boldly going where Captain Cook has gone
before is published by Henry Holt online
at Henry Holt calm